chers amis alors que nous arrivons au
terme de ce congrès permettez moi de
m'associer à l'hommage rendu ce matin
par françois à valéry giscard d'estaing
à celui qui a tant fait pour l'europe
pour la france et pour l'auvergne à
celui à qui la famille du centre à qui
notre famille politique doit de temps
avec une pensée bien sûr pour celles et
ceux d'entre nous qui ont été ses
compagnons de route et qui ont tant
accompli à ses côtés avec une pensée
toute particulière pour françois est
pour toi cher marielle les images d
archives cl émouvante que nous venons de
revoir nous les devons à l'équipe du
siège que je veux remercier en votre nom
à tous pour l'organisation de cette
grande et belle journée des changes
merci à fabien héloïse gina olivia
virginie caroline philomena delphine
martin vincent alexandre alan malo
carole et françois et aux commandos de
bénévoles qui ont mis toute la journée
le feu sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est aussi cette équipe de choc qui a
eu la lourde charge d'organiser les
élections internes par voie électronique
pour qu'elle puisse se tenir en dépit du
contexte et veut naturellement félicité
les élus à commencer par le premier
d'entre eux notre président françois
bayrou qui continuera comme il l'a
toujours fait à porter haut et fort la
voix singulière de démocrates et la
bannière orange et du modem bravo et
merci à toi mon cher françois félicité
aussi les conseillers nationaux les
présidents départementaux les
conseillers départementaux le nouveau
président des jeunes démocrates
auguste mothe et son bureau national
récemment installé remercier bien sûr
tous les sortants qui ont animé avec
passion
notre famille politique pendant trois
ans alors que nous arrivons au terme de
ce congrès permettez moi aussi de me
réjouir de voir notre famille rassemblée
fidèle à ses valeurs est mobilisé pour
agir alors que notre pays notre europe
et peut-être notre humanité sont à la
croisée des chemins
mobilisés pour que dans le monde qui
s'ouvre devant nous les idées que nous
défendons depuis toujours prennent toute
leur place je pense à l'idée d'une
france plus juste qui prend valeur
d'impératifs alors que la crise sans
précédent que nous traversons risque
d'affaiblir encore les plus petits les
plus fragiles fragilité des territoires
sur lesquels notre cher jacqueline
gourault veille avec la tension et la
détermination que nous le connaissons
fragilité de la jeunesse de cette
génération qu'ovide qui subit la crise
de plein fouet et dont nous refusons
avec vous chers sarah el ali shair
nathalie et limaces qu'elles soient
sacrifiés fragilité de notre modèle
économique et social que le virus a mis
à genoux pour le remettre sur pieds il
est urgent que s'accélère la transition
écologique que les fruits de la
croissance soit partagée et que soit
conforté les solidarité avec les
familles avec les personnes âgées avec
les personnes en situation de handicap
autant de combats que mène patrick
mignola les députés du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale comme nos
sénateurs avec un discernement et un
sens du dialogue qui honore notre
famille politique je pense à l'idée
d'une europe plus forte plus solidaire
plus indépendantes comme thierry breton
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure l'europe est
de retour avec un plan de relance commun
avec une dette commune avec des
ressources propres
c'est évidemment fondamental mais
l'histoire ne peut s'arrêter là
le moment est venu d'aller plus loin
dans la constitution d'une force
d'intervention européenne
gage de notre indépendance n'est ce pas
cher geneviève darrieussecq
le moment est venu de mettre fin au
drame qui se joue à nos portes en
méditerranée dans la manche ou encore
récemment en seine-saint-denis avec
marielle de sarnez à la tête de la
commission des affaires étrangères
avec nos parlementaires européens avec
le parti démocrate européen nous devons
être au rendez vous de ces grands défis
je pense enfin à l'idée d'une démocratie
revivifiée
dans une république apaisée nous
récusons la violence sous toutes ses
formes et nous disons que dans une
république
ap
et son respecter les différences la
diversité le pluralisme
c'est pourquoi nous défendons une
certaine vision de la laïcité
certaine vision du mode de scrutin parce
que nous croyons que c'est dans la
confrontation des points de vue que se
noue le consensus parce que nous croyons
que ce consensus peut se nouer au
parlement et je veux saluer le talent
rare est reconnu de tous avec lequel
marc fesneau exercent les
responsabilités exigeante qui sont les
siennes une démocratie revivifiée
suppose aussi de faire échec à
l'abstention
les élections en bavière les élections
aux etats-unis ont montré qu'il n'y a
pas de fatalité que les français ne
doivent pas avoir à choisir entre leurs
droits civiques et leur santé à
l'initiative de françois bayrou
nous avons lancé il ya quelques jours un
grand chantier sur le sujet un groupe de
travail auquel vous êtes invités à
participer
une consultation citoyenne qui sera
lancée dans les prochains jours avec
pour objectif de faire des propositions
mais aussi de mettre en oeuvre les
meilleures pratiques dès les prochains
scrutins
car oui mes chers amis nous serons
appelés à défendre nos priorités aux
élections de juin prochain
souhaitons qu'elle soit l'occasion
d'alliance victorieuse avec nos
partenaires que je remercie de leur
présence avec nous aujourd'hui dans le
respect de nos différences mais avec une
ambition en partage avec alice le moral
avec richard ramos et toute l'équipe du
secrétariat général et du siège nous
serons aux côtés des candidats et des
mouvements départementaux ses priorités
qui sont les nôtres nous les défendrons
au delà de juin 2021 avec 2022 en ligne
de mire le chantier de réflexion que
nous avons lancé il y a un an
université 133 auquel vous avez été un
millier à participer va se poursuivre et
il viendra je l'espère nourrir le
travail essentiel le travail
indispensable engagées par françois
bayrou haut commissariat au plan pour
donner à la france de nouveaux horizons
et de nouvelles espérances dans les
temps 20 certain que nous traversons
cultivons ce désir qui nous anime de
changer le monde et d'influer sur le
cours des choses
c'est cela le rôle d'un mouvement
politique celui d'éveiller les
consciences de produire des idées
nouvelles et de les mettre en oeuvre
si vous êtes là aujourd'hui c'est que
vous partagez cette même conviction
alors que vive le modem que vive la
république
et que vive la france